pourquoi le café te donne envie d'aller
aux toilettes tu la connais cette envie
pressante durant la pause Kawa c'est
parce que tu viens de boire un laxatif
naturel ce n'est pas à cause de la
caféine la preuve le coca ou le Red Bull
en ont plein ça te donne de la pêche pas
l'envie d'en couler une le responsable
c'est la cyclorogénique du café qui
augmente le taux d'acide gastrique dans
ton estomac il y a aussi de la gastrite
une hormone accélérant les mouvements de
l'intestin voire 5 tasses par jour c'est
à quoi finir à l'hôpital déshydraté mais
à dos normal c'est pas dangereux et ça
n'affecte que trois personnes sur 10
c'est toujours mieux de manger quelque
chose en même temps que ton café sinon
ton estomac travaille pour rien ce qui
créerait des inflammations internes tu
sais maintenant